bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale
télé spéciale grand champion de
l'histoire avec jérôme on fera ça lui
jérôme c'est lui stephen alors dans
cette émission on va voir un grand
champion des années
alors maintenant on commence à approcher
70-80 même pas ce qu'il a il a quand
même poursuivi est compris dans l'ère
moderne c est fini claire oui ton et
hésitation est tout à fait légitime
parce que et film j'ai l'air une
carrière extrêmement longue
il a fait preuve d'une longévité assez
extraordinaire puisque pour te donner un
exemple il a participé 23 fois au
championnat du rss à la fin des années
40 et le début des années 80 ouais c'est
ça donc c'est véritablement quelqu'un
qui a croisé tous les grands joueurs qui
a disputé tous les cycles zone aux
interzones haut pour le titre mondial
était une très très longue carrière
marquée par des résultats
quelquefois mitigés mais il a toujours
posé beaucoup de problèmes à tous les
jours qu'il a rencontrés alors qu'ils
fument galère
comment s'est déroulé sa grande carrière
alors efym petrovic galère et les en
ukraine en 1925 et au dessin horde et ça
c'est très particulier parce que c'est
une ville qu'on appelle la new york
russe l'époque
à la suite de la guerre turcs aux russes
du xviiie siècle en fait c'est devenu un
comptoir commercial et cette ville qui
comptait à peine 2000 de 3000 habitants
en 1800 elle compte au moment de la
naissance des films galère plus de six
cent mille habitants
c'est une ville très cosmopolite on y
croise des italiens des bulgares des
français des turcs qui viennent faire
affaire
il y a aussi une forte communauté juive
jusqu'à 30% de la population et qui bat
qui aident à la prospérité de la ville
qui travaillent dans l'artisanat dans
les affaires et dont les films galère
est lui-même issu d'accords alors c'est
une ville qui connaît qui est aussi à la
pointe de la révolution le cuirassé
potemkine et odessa
c'est ce sont des choses qui sont très
liés donc c'est une ville qui est la
pointe de la révolution et de fait elle
devient une ville symbole elle est
reprise par l'armée rouge les reprises
par les blancs occupée par les français
reprises à nouveau par l'armée rouge
et de fait il ya souvent des règlements
de comptes politiques pour la population
de cette ville qui subit des exactions
et des pogroms dans les années 20 30 au
moment de la naissance des films galère
d'accord donc il arriva début de la de
la guerre en inde en 40 il ya 15 ans ou
qui commence a sans doute déjà être déjà
un bon joueur à 15 ans il s'est déjà
joué mais sa progression est entravée
bien sûr par la guerre ce qui est
mobilisée comme mécanicien dans
l'aviation
donc bien sûr il effectue son service il
est tout jeune puisque né en 25 qui doit
avoir 18 ans 43 tout simplement
et à la fin de la guerre mais elle
continue sa carrière de joueur en
ukraine avec des répons résultats au
championnat d'ukraine pour commencer il
finit 5e 6e dans les années 40 49 et
finit même par remporter ce championnat
d'ukraine qu'à quatre reprises en 50 57
58 59
et puis ensuite il s'attaque aux
championnats du rss avec une première
participation à 49 et une dernière
participation en 1985
oui on voit bien là langil annoncé l'itf
38 ans au cours desquels il dispute 23
championnats du rss donc il a connu
aussi comme les joueurs de ces années là
le début aussi du classement elo parce
qu'il ya un bruit ils arrivent en
soixante dix 70 puisque jusque là on
avait des maîtres des grands maîtres
il a d'ailleurs obtenu le titre de grand
maître international dans le premier
coût convoi de tous les joueurs qu'ils
ont eue en 1952 au début des années 50
le titre de maîtres et grands maîtres
sont créés par la fidh officialisé et
devienne la seule mesure de la force des
joueurs
et puis ensuite on a le fameux
classement elo qui est introduit dans
les années 70 comme tu as dit et qui
permet de mesurer de façon plus fine la
force des joueurs quoique la force du
hello et quelquefois marche aurait selon
un correspondant bien mais bon c'est pas
forcément à dix points près non c'est
pas absolue c'est pas nous c'est dur
absolue à laisser grandir qui marche
assez bien on voit à peu près quelle est
la force du joueur grâce à leur aide
mais il ya des joueurs qui ont des
victoires factice arrive ça dans un
autre débat mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que j'allais arrêter un jour d'une
grande longévité qu'il a remporté deux
titres du rss d'une période où le héros
n'existaient pas c'était 1955 et un
autre période où il existait ce 1979 il
ya 24 ans entre ces deux titres de
champion du rss c'est à dire la
longévité et le maintien dans le temps
de sa force
quelles sont ses plus grands résultats
alors ces grands résultats c'est des
victoires dans les grands tournois comme
mike hayes et par exemple ce sont aussi
des médailles d'or ou des médailles
d'argent aux olympiades avec l'urss
puisque il a mis sa longévité au service
de l'urss de des années 50 jusqu'en 1980
aux olympiades de malte oui obtient
encore une médaille donc à un très fort
joueur pour lui et à ses centres forts
joueurs de tournois aussi qui a eu des
résultats un peu plus mitigé dans le
dans les tournois des candidats il a
jamais eu la possibilité de disputer
réellement les titres mondial il est
éliminé deux fois en quarts de finale où
il s'était confié légère dans les dix
premiers il est déjà dans les dix
premiers vie reste dans les dix premiers
c'est une valeur sûre mais il ne
parvient jamais à arriver dans le top
niveau des deux trois premiers mondiaux
tout à fait d'accord on va avoir une
petite image
tout de suite maintenant sur l'écran où
on voit des films galère alors ici il
est au fond à droite absolument juste
derrière un jeune joueur qui est déjà
champion du monde à l'époque puisqu'on
en 1981 il s'agit d'un atelier karpov
voilà mais pas depuis longtemps fin ça
fait cinq ans que les champions du monde
effectivement karpov
donc voilà on voit le jeune karpov
devant injuste et film galère donc c'est
l'équipe du rss qui rencontrent ici
alors c'est sans doute une olympiade
c'est l'olympia de malte de 1981 et
l'urss rencontre l'islande
il ya plusieurs choses intéressante à
noter sur cette photographie la première
chose qui peut frapper c'est de voir un
atelier karpov effet une galère qui
jouent sur des échiquiers qui sont au
mieux en vinyle au pire en carton un
essai une olympiade
oui ça a l'air d'être les pieds simple
et il hérite des pièces en plastique et
des horaires c'est assez amusant
d'autres choses amusantes sont à noter
on distingue en haut à droite la
composition de l'équipe du rss avec
trois grands maîtres et un maître
international
karpov galère et puis hein mais je ne m
international qui joue au quatrième
échiquier on devine son et cg point
casque imagine que c'est garry kasparov
évidemment c'est certain qu'ils aient à
ce moment seulement je suis j'ose dire
maître international
mais au dessus c'est peut-être beliatski
je ne sais pas bon oui mais l on voit
patron va pas traîner on remarquera
aussi qu'il ya trois maîtres
internationaux dans la composition de
l'équipe d'islande
aujourd'hui dans toutes les compositions
quasiment d'equipe des olympiades on a
que des grands maîtres
on a que des grands même alors décrit ce
land est un grand pays de schengen
absolument avec des joueurs comme genre
personnes
dans les années 80 d'ailleurs c'est un
peu comme la hollande c'est à dire petit
pays mais très très grande
voilà très très grande équipe de joueurs
entrés très fort joueur avec une vraie
tradition bien une vraie tradition dans
les pays nordiques la nuit polaire y est
d'un petit peu parce que il ya des
promulgation officielle et des
recommandations officielles des états je
crois que c'est en islande ou en suède
que l'état recommande notamment la
pratique des échecs pendant les nuits
polaires pour éviter la dépression
ah oui oui pour s'occuper d'avoir une
activité en lumière puis de faire
travailler un peu mais d'accord non
c'est pas bête hein c'est intéressant
donc je savais pas cette histoire
explique pourquoi carsen dans ces chiens
aussi aujourd'hui fait partie des
familles des joueurs des meilleurs
joueurs du monde
oui il y avait les nordiques il ya des
choses à dire il vous connais pas de
joueur un peu extraordinaire
et donc voilà donc cette photo de et
film
efym galère alors on va illustrer
la carrière l'extraordinaire carrière
défini hier qu'a rencontré les plus
grands il a joué donc je pense qu'il a
joué presque contre tous les champions
du monde de ces époques la ilaha illa il
il a joué petrossian et je sais pas ce
qui il a joué
karpov il a joué fischer jeux les plus
grands ont mémorial alix et en 1975 et
termine devant karpov corse noyce
pesquié petrossian qui ne trompent pas
ce sont des joueurs qu'ils soient sans
disputant 23 championnats du rss
on imagine qu'il a rencontré tout ce qui
s'est fait de mieux depuis blood vinik
jusqu'à kasparov
voilà donc on va passer à la partie que
je vais mettre avant qu'on la voit sur
l'écran ici voilà on va passer à un
autre parti du jour donc pour illustrer
le talent de ce grand maître alex
exceptionnelle longévité et qui a trusté
le haut du pavé même s'il n'a pas réussi
à atteindre la finale du monde il a
quand même marqué son époque
il faisait partie des grands maîtres à
battre s'ils ont voulu devenir
championne money ferry passé devant j'ai
l'air mais c'est qu'ils n'étaient pas
simples et ici c'est une partie qui fait
partie sans doute d'un des sommet de la
carrière de gnr puisqu'il joue petroci
dans 63 63 c'est l'année où tu es trop
chiant et champion du monde ici sa
première année en tant que champion du
monde en tout cas me défendre a ensuite
son titre petrossian face à ce parce
qu'il 66 donc il est au top de sa forme
petrossian c'était à l'époque un joueur
dont on disait qu'il était imbattable il
dit faisait énormément de nuls et 7 est
quasiment impossible de le battre il
perdait quasiment jamais gagné sur des
parties mais surtout ne perdez pas c'est
ce qui lui a permis d'ailleurs d'être
champion du monde
on pensait qu'on pourrait pas l'autre
tout simplement inventé fatigue qui
deviennent trop vieux
we bought vinik avait plusieurs fois
perdu son titre de champion du monde
il avait repris dans des matchs revanche
quand il a perdu contre petrossian 5 2
il n'a pas fait valoir ce droit au match
revanche parce qu'il a vraisemblablement
compris qu'il était un peu sur le déclin
de toute façon il y avait la guerre mur
qu'il était pour lui un franchisseur
petroci un nom très grand joueur peut
être un conte sur lequel on reviendra
bien sûr dans ce catalogue d'écrans
champion d'échecs voilà alors galère
entament cette partie avec le coût du
plan du roi eu 2e 4 ouvertures que l'on
dit ouverte mais petrossian alors qui
justement lui alors aimait beaucoup les
systèmes fermés et il sert toujours y
jouer notamment la carro cannes c'est à
dire la quarantaine c'est à dire le coup
ici le petit coup c'est si ce qui est
bon mais un coût qui justement va
essayer de verrouiller un peu le jeu
celui de d5 en évitant les grands débuts
ouvert et les jouets peuvent d'ailleurs
quand il a tenté d jouissant n'est pas
con sortie oui les parties comptent
fischer où il tente la sicilienne et
puis finalement il perd mais donc
justement on va voir ici le style de
petrossian qui est typique dans cette
partie puisque il rentre pas dans les
grands débuts ouvert il rentre pas dans
le sens qui rentre pas dans ces cinq ils
jouent pas le jeu ouvert et joue aussi
soit l'âge ou la française qui est une
autre façon de fermer le jeu on peut
jouer par ces six ou par 6,6 y avait des
cinq on a une partie mais sur
intéressant mais qui est moins nouvel
art avec moins de possibilités tactiques
mon ouverture des quatre de la part de
gnr c'est normal on occupe le centre
puisque les noirs ne font rien pour
contrer cette ouverture
et voilà le coup suivant logique des
cinq qui attaquent le plan cadre et qui
pose tout de suite une question aux
blancs c'est ce qu'il faut prendre le
pion noir c'est faisable mais ça ne
donne rien de particulier en termes
d'initiatives
alors si on reprend une position
symétrique on a simplifié un peu et
c'est une position qui
voilà ne crée pas de tension partie de
déséquilibre si on veut gagner il faut
créer des déséquilibres
c'est mieux on peut aussi pousser bien
sûr le pion aux cinq qui peut joindre 5
c'est la variante c'est vraiment la
variante fermé c'est le point de fermer
alors ça donne aux blancs quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est d'avoir un pion 5
qui contrôle les cases des 6 7 6 ouais
ce qui limite un peu le développement du
cavalier noir ou bien si on vient ici
voilà on contrôle la case d66 et f6 là
c'est une autre variante c'est parce
qu'a choisi j'ai l'air on veut le voir
tout de suite puisqu'ils jouent le conte
classique cavale et c3 on défend le
client 4 avec lecavalier
alors c'est un coût tout à fait normal
dans la française et le coup suivant est
tout à fait logique aussi c'est le coup
le standard on joue fou j'ai quatre
foulées 4 pardon on cloue le cavalier
donc on réitère la menace puis on prend
2,4 donc ça explique le coup suivant
rien d'autres variantes on peut tenter
des choses comme un objet 4 ici pour
attaquer j'essaie de profiter du fait
que le fouet ben ali parti de dieu à des
partis mais plutôt les deux jeux très
tendue mais bon c'est sain de chaussée
show control et gants m oui parce que là
on est quand même beaucoup de pièces aux
130 prix si on prend le cas tient aussi
le pion des quatre plus tard qu'ils se
rendent prise donc c'est un coup
d'objets cas d'ailleurs que sûr que je
crois on peut répondre des coups qu'on
aura une fuite des choses comme ça on
protège et puis on laisse la tension au
centre est bon mon avis c'est autre
chose on va pas analyser la le début
c'est pas le but ici est celle là coup
classique le coût standard dans cette
position et alors là normalement les
fait normalement usuellement les noirs
jouent le coup c'est 5 assez vite de
façon à attaquer la base du centre blanc
puisque là on une minichaîne de pions et
et quand ton ami michel d'options c'est
bien d'attaquer le centre en plus on
sait que ce soit avec les noirs et les
blancs que si on peut jouer le coup
c'est 5 avant de sortir le 15 lycées
mieux puisqu'on a utilisé son pion à bon
escient pour attaquer le centre avant
que le cas l'histoire parce que si vous
sortez lecavalier avant d'avoir vu ce
combat vous bloquez votre pion donc
voilà donc alors on peut jouer c'est
simple tweet ou le coup de petrossian
qui est sans doute un peu plus prudent
un peu moins agressif mais bon aussi
bien sûr c'est le coût des six b6
n'empêche pas même consolide la presse
que la possibilité c'est sec
c'est-à-dire en cas de prise des blancs
peut envisager de reprendre du pillon ce
qui donne un très fort centre de pions
brute noir mais c'est aussi la
possibilité de sortir très vite le fou
sur la case à 6 alors c'est important
parce qu'en jouant au cices on a un mur
et se fout donc quand je vois un v6 on
montre que voilà on a toujours la
possibilité de l'activer sur cette
grande diagonale et pourquoi pas
l'échanger contre ce fou qui lui par
contre effectivement est un fou que les
blancs bien gardé puisque les pions sur
noir donc on aime bien avoir ce fou
d'attac qu'est un vrai fou d'attac un
puits en cas d' échange des fous en a
six il y aura une reprise avec le
cavalier b 8 ans qui permettent de
développer du même coup et d'avoir
encore un oeil supplémentaires sur
laquelle ses seins ou aymeric qui permet
en plus exactement d'un réunionnais sur
la casse et 5 et après c'est celle qu'on
peut envisager si les blancs ne font
rien de recycler le carrier par ces sept
ce genre de choses donc b6 kalev 3 donc
logique aux développe un tranquille et
où se développent en plus qu'elle lève
trois bombes l avantage aux points de
contrôle et les 15 centres allemands
faire comment on peut commenter le coup
que le cabinet 3c archi naturel logique
et surtout qui est en cours de
développement
donc là petrossian bain se pressent
toujours pas il joue le coup un peu
étrange dame 17 alors d'amd cet email à
la dame sur blanc bon mais il a un petit
oeil sur les cases blanches
pourquoi pas
ce qui est complémentaire de ce fou ici
de cases de cases noires c'est un coût
de développement de la dame qui était un
peu mystérieux gens venir je suis pas
sûr que j'aurais joué j'aurais aimé
jouer ce genre de coup ça fait rien pour
le centre moi j'aurais plutôt j'aimerais
plus le coup c'est celle à la limite le
couffo à 6 pour échanger très vite mon
mauvais fou parce que ce n'est pas
insurmontable sur mes pions contre bons
fous moi le ku'damm 17 pour comparer
c'est un coût de développement de la
dame
il se justifie alors on met la dame sur
blanc on a le feu sur blanc c'est que
quand mon ami sur les pions aussi
sûrement ici on rajoute delà du contrôle
sur les cases blanches parce qu'on peut
avec les blancs à avoir certaines une
invasion possible et notamment des
échecs ou des cavaliers qui peuvent
venir sur ces cas là on en est pas là fu
d2 alors logique en jouant food et 2 et
bien simplement de vol peu fou et ont
des clous le cas à l'essai 3 ce qui est
tout ce qui peut être utile et notamment
ça évite aussi en cas de prix ça peut
éviter de doubler les pions parce qu'ici
jusqu'ici en cas de présence et 3b
prince et rang on avait des pions qu'on
a des prix ont doublé
ce qui est classique de la française
honore les blancs ne craignent pas ça
c'est pas trop trop gênant avec un pion
c2 c3 des quatre nombre de ses cadres
souvent très vite et puis souvent même
on a besoin de tout simplement d'avoir
dopé russie parce que quand les noirs
prennent en d4 on prend du pillon et
puis on a un deuxième qui peu enclin à
protéger la chaîne toujours en réserve
voilà donc c'est des pions doublé mais
qui sont proches du centre donc ils ont
aussi
intérêt défensif en bons fous des deux
alors sous des deux je sais pas si ça
menace directement des choses je pense
pas mais petrossian je vous ai fait un
bon ça alors ça ne s'est pas commenter
ça c'est un coup elle peut dire que
c'est un coup prudent alors on comprend
pas bien pourquoi on a je fous b4 il
faut ensuite puisque ça contribue pas au
développement il peut estimer petrossian
qufu des deux étangs de toute nation de
fort développement sur le fou est pas
hyper actif en d2 et que le temps perdu
par les blancs est compensé par ce qu'il
faut ensuite un jour de faux et fuite il
dit me finance je vais rien changer j'ai
pas envie d'échanger mon fou et je vais
peut-être me développe continuer à être
développée par cas mais les sept plus
tard et puis je ne me réserve la
possibilité de ses 5 parce que si je
garde le fourbe et quatre sur ces 5
les blancs jouent à trois et ça oblige
le faut c'est changer en tête petrossian
jousse et varane pour éviter cet échange
assez de ce sont des baisses se sont
relayés tentative de développement
théorique
là aussi on est dans une époque où on
cherche en corner 63 les ordinateurs
sont toujours pas là donc on cherche
encore les meilleures façons de traiter
les positions est bon pourquoi pas et la
bombe et génère lui se dit blé noir ont
perdu du temps j'ai connu trois pistes
développer il n'a quasiment pas à me
donner cette messe que c'est vrai un
vrai développement pas claires donc je
commence à attaquer direct à quatre
alors à 4 un double intérêt 1 j'ai un
oeil sur b5
donc je peux mettre une pièce en bessin
qu'avec en étant extrêmement bien
protégée y compris par le pion mais je
peux aussi envisager des a5 de façon à
prendre en d6 et rajouter du contrôle
sur la colonne à en libérant matoury
signe donc je fais pression sur le pion
à 7
j'empêche si j'arrive à échanger en
décision n'empêche toute velléité des
noirs de se développer via à 6 puisque
fou et tour protégerez la case assiste
donc c'est un coup d' attaque un coup
d'expansion elle dame qui profite
finalement du louvoiement des noirs dans
l'ouverture avec ce coup fourré suite
qui est pas claire et qui quelque part
les blancs d'ibm et a rien fait pour
m'empêcher de consolider de mon centre
on sent très fort pour l'instant tulle
attaque pas donc je n'y a pas de menace
contre moi je peut engager des
opérations à elle c'est un principe
stratégique général si votre centre et
consolider vous pouvez très clairement
affaiblir ou en tout cas provoquer des
attaques sur les ailes il n'y a pas de
danger de vous faire ouvrir la position
en mettant à jour de faiblesse parce que
si vous vous attaquez sur les ailes sans
avoir protégé le centre quand le centre
explose eh bien vous vous attaque sur
l'ale vont s'avérer être des cibles au
contraire des cibles d'attaqués
ici la menace c'est à ça que je pense a
sévèrement parce que clairement assassin
campêche ses 5 à 5 campêche ses sincères
si effectivement il ya cinq c5 je peux
prendre un b 6 et on peut pas reprendre
à cause du visa bis entre les deux tours
donc à 5 est une vraie menace donc ça
explique le coup suivant des noirs
qu'avait laissé six et là on n'aime pas
cette position une version on est un peu
joueur n'aime pas ça parce que on a ici
trois pièces quasiment en enfilade et ça
donne une excellente case de
développement pour le fouet fin avec des
clous âge qui plus est avec le pion 17
qui a avancé en b6 et donc qui ne
protège plus voilà le cavalier les cases
blanches sont affaiblis autour du autour
du cavalier et pour bien sûr le cavalier
f3 est encore loin le fou ne cloue pas
encore mais on n'aime pas cet alignement
n'a pas omis de dire qu'il faudra va
falloir assez vite que les noirs jouent
à 6 pour protéger cette case b5 parce
qu'il met du coup ça affaiblit encore
plus chaque fois que vous jouez un coup
d'abord ainsi un cookie des bleus
toujours pas de pièce et puis à chaque
fois que vous avancez des pions vais
vous donner des idées de cibles dans le
camp ennemi dans votre propre camp ici
en l'occurrence bon alors ce début de
petrossian est pas il n'est pas
recommandé un je crois que en plus
dangereux car il sait si ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure c'est constant on ignore
maintenant le pousser scène donc jamais
on va attaquer ce centre fort alors fou
eux deux le gellert maintenant vont
arriver par enlever cinq puisque à 6
obligerait les changes
et ça c'est un peu du noir essayer de
forcer ça les arrangerait bien sûr les
blancs retards de salaires qu'ils ont
toujours ils ont l'idée d'aller ici mais
au bon camp mais quand ils auront la
possibilité de devenir sans être chassés
ce qui est sûr c'est que pour l'instant
et plus d'histoires deux fois 6 voilà
alors fou des trois serait sans doute
une erreur parce que si on avait joué au
foot est roi est bien légale idée simple
de [ __ ] calais b 4 parce que un jour à
quatre on a quand même une petite
faiblesse sur la case big apple
puisqu'on peut pas chasser le cavalier
en b 4 on aura attaqué le fou et on
retrouve la possibilité de jouer ces
cinq donc faux de et malin puisque ce
cas là mais quand on attaque rien donc
ça empêche pas les blancs de jouer par
exemple le fameux coup à cinq qui
empêche ses cinq encore une fois puisque
apprend b6 menace et puis en plus qui
active a beaucoup c'est tour sur donc
faux de petrossian se résout à
développer la seule pièce vraiment qu'il
y a la troupe qui encore trouver une
case c'est le cavalier de 7 alors ce
cavalier et bien on peut envisager de
venir en f 5 regarder puisque maintenant
on a quand même une petite idée pour les
noirs c'est de faire pression sur des
quatre avec les deux cavaliers et
comment les blancs défendent c'est pas
clair pour l'instant y'a que ça
et la dame ici ne protège pas puisque
elle est bloquée par le fouet trois dans
le food et de parents donc c'est une
vraie menace positionnelle que ce cookie
religieux 7
donc petit rock voilà est là mais
pourquoi pas il aurait pu tenter sein
qui encore une fois c'est possible pour
petrossian mais peut-être que sur cloud
l'idée c'était peut-être maintenant de
jouer au foot et 5 qui tous et en cas de
assiste peut-être de prendre et le
cavalier est cinquième à le placer
puisqu'on peut jouer g4
cette fois le clavier ne peut pas venir
acheter quelle est sa classe naturelle
en fait puisque le coeur et les protéger
il faut revenir la maison bois et du
coup l'ubs les blancs font leur
expansion classica les lois parce qu'on
va jouer ensuite après j'ai 4 ans a joué
4 puis f5 protégé par la tour et on
attaque cette fameuse chaîne de pions
c'est le plan à long terme des blancs et
le font ils dans cette variante sans
grand danger puisque
il n'y a pas de risque de perdre le pion
des 4es pas de risque d'ouverture par
ces cinq est toujours pareil c'est que
le centre est extrêmement mince comment
solide c'est le risque de la poussière 4
pour les blancs dans la française parce
que en cas de ces cinq et deux reprises
par le fouet fuite
bien sûr on à la diagonale qui est
ouverte vers le roi blanc bien sûr en
grande difficulté tout à fait ça peut
très dangereux a contrario donc mais
dans cette position ses coups que les
500 doubtful b5 et subit doji 4 très
vite et il ya des soucis pour les noirs
donc là petrossian la joue autrement
pour attaquer le centre c'est une autre
façon de l'attaqué de la française y
joue et 6 alors ça c'est classique en
juin m6 ben c'est simple on attaque non
pas la base ici mais la tête
alors c'est possible ici plutôt attaquer
la tête puisqu'elle est défendu bien sûr
mais si secret une vraie menace de prise
dans le 5 et de 6 quand les blancs vont
reprendre on va libérer le pion des cinq
de pions de ses mousses pourra
potentiellement avancé endroit le centre
qui peut être fort ça devait être fort
et puis on peut parfois même avoir un
pion aux cinq faible parce que
pour ajouter des cabinets attaque etc on
va voir la suite tourvain logique tout
simplement j'ai l'air actif ça tout ça
c'est extrêmement naturelle maintenant
qu arrive si ça a été jouée le thème il
est simple c'est qu'en cas de prise bien
il ya une colonne ouverte ou semi
ouverte qui s'ouvre et puis à leur rang
derrière on a toujours par ok on elle
fournit fit donc on y voit le décor est
planté c'est à dire que les blancs une
forte avance de développement l'attak
des noirs sur le centre semble être un
peu lente finalement petroci
envoyez-vous a pris des moyens un peu
penaud on de laon pour attaquer ce sens
mais il le fait quand même voyez donc il
va quand même dans cette danse et
ouverture donc pris je prends de prendre
au sein comprend 1,5 parce qu'on veut
boucher cette colonne on veut pas
laisser les blancs maintenant jouer des
coups comme fou bessèges qui ouvre tout
le jeu contre le roi c'est pas le moment
donc il faut prendre 5 pour boucher
puisque après et la colonne avec l'idée
que si les blancs prennent par exemple
par le cavalier qui attaquent adan
on reprend du cavalier et après la prise
par le pion la colonne est bouché sur la
tour but contre son pion donc le roi
n'est pas en véritable danger et la
magnifique coup blessé le moment parce
que regarder toutes les pièces blanches
sont sortis 1 2 3 4
la tour est activée la torah même et
active puisqu'elle est à un coup de
jouer à 5 qui ouvre totalement sa
colonne et de roy est à l'abri donc
c'est le moment ici pour les blancs de
faire de prendre des vraies décisions
là j'ai l'air donc du coup ne reprend
pas le pion aux savoirs des c'est
magnifique
il joue de très jolis dessins et ça y
est on y est c'était dit ce qu'on avait
dit tout à l'heure à kas v5 est faible
on a des pièces ici en enfilade la
menace blanche est énorme puisque c'est
carrier prendre cinq attaques
la dame et attaque le câble et c6 en
même temps et à 6 ici ne suffit pas 6
suffit pas raciste ne suffit pas puisque
cavaliers prend 1,5 attac la dame alors
si je ne suis pas un jeu récupère le bio
en attaquant la dame je peux pas prendre
le cavalier puisque les coûts et est le
seul coup ici qui perd pas de pièce si
je demandais en limite évidemment je
perds le cavalier donc il faut jouer fou
le pardon dame en d6 et là on regarde et
il ya le fameux cavaliers h5 échec
voilà ça en tête d'abord prendre en c6
pour éloigner le cavalier eaux cette
on peut aussi prendre ses six comme ça
on craint page et si c'est vrai mais ça
c'est encore plus fort parce que
lecavalier qui gêne le moins il peut
même pas venir recettes
il ya encore moins de cases je pensais
encore plus fort parce qu'on a envie de
garder le clouage ici puis de regarder
ce cas rien qui gêne pas parce que vous
volera si le roi va en des huit
cavaliers cavalières vii c'est matin
alors il peut jouer j'ai 6 mai sur g6
le problème est immédiat lord et c'est
simple on joue simplement d'un f3 menace
la 1007 que font les noirs maintenant il
faut mais il faut faire quelque chose
on va prendre le fou mais si on prend le
fou on peut choisir de jouer simplement
d'amener cet échec
trois des huit forcé et ont gardé des
coups comme ici d'un v6 menace à la fois
d'en prendre tour et qu'il qualifie cet
échec et la dame étant prises et alors
si on prend du câble et on reprend
simplement du pion qui attaquent la dame
et la tour et encore perdu on a au moins
gagné la qualité et la taxe n'est pas
fini donc en fait l'exposition est archi
écrasante voyez qu'on n'a pas le temps
on fait donc sur france info b5 la
menace comme les prendre 5 est trop
forte donc et rauscher n'a pas le choix
il joue le seul coup qui tiennent à la
position qu'elle j 6 kg 6 avec l'idée
que si on prend du cavalier et là on
peut prendre de l'autre mais on voit
quand même que c'est plaisant c'est
vraiment pas plaisant dans ce type de
position il faut pas que les blancs
attendent
on est dans une position ici ou là tac
peut être forte puissante chaque coup
doit marquer parce qu'il faut pas que
les blancs les noirs étant de jouer à 6
tranquillement de façon à enlever ce fou
qui pour l'instant est extrêmement
puissant dont qui pour garder la
puissance de ce fou il faut être actif
donc j'ai l'air est actif et il fait
tout de suite quand même qu'avec prendre
5 donc sa force
la réponse de petrossian est là
simplement pour prendre cinq magnifiques
vois la magnifique pourquoi parce que
cette tour en venant ici bombe n'est pas
en prise du cavalier puisqu'hier clouage
est par contre elle cloue le pion aux 6
et ça c'est important parce que ça
menace cavaliers prendre pions le
cavalier est protégé par la tour et
n'est pas prenable par le pion aux 6 à
cause du plonge donc la revoilà ça gagne
un point central net avec une position
écrasante puisqu'une puis aussi de lier
une faiblesse en plus chronique et de
manière plus générale quand ils reprise
possible sur une case faible puisque la
case de 5,5 à ce faible
il faut par prendre du plomb il faut
reprendre de la pièce las il avait
repris du plomb mais oui il aurait
bouché la faiblesse des noirs en fait il
leur aurait rendu service
exactement dans le faites pas l'erreur
parce que si vous prenez ici du pion
bien sûr mêmes vautours ne joue plus
vraiment en attaque
elle est pas mal placée en soit elle
défend une pure avancé mais on a plus d'
attaques contre le moins le furoncle tu
réussisses devient moins faible d'un
coup depuis aussi ses protégés en fait
dans le pion
tout à fait donc c'est moins fort c'est
moins fort que la partie après calais
g15 simplement tout reprendre 5 avec une
position déjà extrêmement tendue pour
petrossian qui a fait un début comme on
l'a vu trop mou peut-être une sans doute
trop mou et geiler ne laisse pas passer
cette occasion donc à 6 c'est le moment
il faut absolument sans levée de ce club
qui devient infernal bon là il ya pas
trop le choix pour les blancs parce que
si on enlève le fou évidemment le
cavalier attaque la tour ce fonds
soutiendra locaux h donc il faut prendre
ici pas le choix faut prendre ces
systèmes processes et c'est l'heure pour
regarder alors on aurait pu choisir tout
de suite qu'elle allait prendre les 5
mais j'ai l'air fait encore un tout
petit peu mieux puisqu'il fait il fait
pas cavalier 5 pardon s'il fait qu'avec
des scènes quand même faut pas me
prendre je crois qu'il avait fait je
crois qu'il avait fait échec d'abord
maintenant il fait cavaler prendre des
cinq quand même et ça y est c'est ce
qu'on disait talent le club est
imprenable sur la tour et le pion aux
6es cloud et donc que font les noirs que
font et noir qui ne sont toujours pas
très développé puisque les deux fous
sont sur leur caisse d'origine le roi
n'a pas roquet est encore au centre et
la diagonale critique de 8 h 5 est
ouverte
exact donc ici il ya plusieurs coups
possibles on peut analyser alors on va
voir que petrossian a choisi le courroux
des sept bons parce qu'il veut il veut
sans doute faire un roc rapidement on
pourrait tenter aussi fou des six on
peut jeter un oeil sur food et 6 alors
l'intérêt de fous des six il est que si
la tour samba évidemment le cas payet
emprise donc ça c'est un vrai problème
il faut quand même gérer ça bon en plus
ça peut préparer le petit rock qui
attaque du coup qu'il est en prise la
tour et le cavalier donc c'est quand
même embêtant
donc il a il fallait que j'ai l'air
prévoit quoi faire dans cette position
alors la variante est la suivante
simplement dame h 5 échecs et si ça
c'est un vrai problème parce que si si
leur appareil vers des mythes des sons
pop qui vais encore le fou pari chèque
on peut faire beaucoup de beaucoup de
menaces de ce type là si on joue ou g6
simplement pour parer les chèques et
bien on n'est pas pressé on joue
simplement la f3 regarder pourquoi parce
qu'on a un vis-à-vis van damme faut le
voir ça un eric adams et 6,7 en l'air et
on menace tout simple cavaliers six
échecs et on gagne la dance et en alaska
les six échecs et le roi peut pas venir
en dix-sept puisque le cavaly ci protège
aussi la case donc ses échecs faut parer
les chèques et après
perdu donc ça ça menace a créé une
menace qu'il faut paraît alors si par
exemple et noir par cette menace par
exemple prenant le pion ces deux bons
copains
imaginons on a toujours quand même la
tour ici quelle emprise
simplement on peut d'abord faire cas bel
échec puis bouger la tour par exemple où
allait prendre la torah 8 ah oui aussi
bien sûr on peut aussi aller prendre
regarder la tour à 8 non seulement ils
m'ont prise mais il y avait aussi la
tour derrière
et sinon on va voir un peu ce qui s'est
passé dans la partie en fait elle c'est
un peu la même chose c'est que si les
noirs ici je vous fous 17 alors fou 17,1
peut être aussi revu un peu cette ce
type de manoeuvre c'est nîmes je vais à
la fois un je vais protéger madame 2 je
laisse car les entreprises trois jeux
menace entre guillemets de faire grand
roque est ce que je peux faire crocs et
a pris grand roque j'aime chez moins
embêtés par ce courage et je suis un peu
à l'abri et puis je laisse les blancs
avec des soucis au centre donc je peux
respirer qu'on en fait donc faut pas
laisser les noirs et spinales pourquoi
laisser respirer et la meilleure façon
de faire c'est de ne pas les laisser
rauque et magnifique coup de geiler
simplement ils se pressent pas
tranquille il vous faut g5 qui empêche
simplement le rock voyez comme il finit
de développement sans se presser et tout
en gardant une pression énorme sur le
camp des des noirs donc là par contre on
se dit oui mais attention parce que
maintenant il ya plus cette histoire de
deux molaires de dames en l'air puisque
je suis protégé par le fou donc je peux
jouer le coup fourré 6 c'est ce que fait
petrossian puisque j'attaque la tour à
tour peut pas venir non plus à f/5
puisque je la prends donc que va-t-il
devenir de ce cavalier
si la tour 101 et là il fallait avoir
calculé ce qui suit ce qui est très
important
j'ai l'air a tout vu ciudad match 5
échecs au un problème pour les noirs
alors à noter que si les noirs
joue le coup ici g6 un peu comme ce
qu'on avait dit tout à l'heure
et bien simplement on peut jouer un coup
comme damas six sans se presser et en
cas de prise de la tour bien pris ce
prise la prise de ce cavalier ici est
empêché par le simple dames g7 attaques
et menaces mais attendent un set puisque
je suis protégé par le fonds donc vous
voyez des coups de canne et suffise à
éviter des des problèmes et il ya
toujours des menaces et marron peugeot
qui avait réussi ces chèques
le roi peut toujours par ok et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on fait contre la mauvaise
qualité je suis pour tours g8 il suffit
pas alors si on joue tour g8 mais on
peut faire dans les prochains jours le
problème attaque la tour et si on joue
tour et fuite qui paraît logique plus
logique puisque là cette fois en fuite
bon on est protégé et puis on peut
envisager de jouer des tours fc est des
choses comme ça pour essayer de s'en
sortir mais ça marche pas non plus
puisqu'on fait quand même par exemple
d'alger cette menace pour matt comment
on fait pour parer le mat et en plus on
menace aussi cavalier f6 échec
il resterait tours et sète quelque chose
comme ça alors à noter que dams et 5
même parce qu'on protège alors bien sûr
on protège ici mais simplement d'abord
un aujourd hui des quatre voies la dame
se trouvait là pas de case ou alors on
peut même jouer cavalier français cet
échec force dans prend suivi du matin
voilà donc là le contour f s'est efforcé
d'accord et là maintenant regardez c'est
simple échec
thomas fuite et ça y est c'est l'heure
du cavalier de venir puisque camani six
échecs
si on vient des 8 2 ans perd la tour
donc il reste que le coup roy
ici le set et là regardez simplement le
fait qu'elle avait les parents achètent
et celle du fou et après la descente
regardez le cavalier attaque la tour
donc on va pouvoir prendre la mort en
demeurant et ses matisse est mat
donc c'est matt extrêmement rapidement
donc sur la match 5 le coup g6 et
simplement contré par le dame si c'est
une invasion sur les cases noires qui
empêche toute prise de la de la toro
s'est noyée de compte tout tienne mais
comme le roi noir et xt sous pression
terrible donc peut être aussi on
comprend ça il faut garder ce pion ici
parce que faut empêcher ces fameux aussi
que six échecs
donc il faut garder le pion dans cette
position donc il joue ben on suit ça
fait peur alors une série de roi et
chute quand même il est fort c'est qu'on
enlève les clous âge donc il ya plus de
cloche du pion donc on peut menacer
pions 30 travailler on peut menacer
peut-être en moins à ce jour mais
surtout de suite qui avait lié prend
entourant donc ici maintenant que j'ai
l'air continue son attaque par dame est
franc et chic
quelle est l'idée de mettre en échec ou
va loin déjà tout simplement alors notez
que maintenant que l'on a bougé il est
des routiers oui peu plus rock et il ne
pourra plus rock et de la partie si même
s'il revient ou 8 ce qui est toujours
possible
alors si le noir venaient 1,8 on est
obligé de regarder un peu à celle du
super party d'attac
regardez magnifique ça c'est le thème
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure avec le coup
que les dames sont envisagées on peut
jouer le coup magnifique tour prend 1,6
quand même mais les emprises oui bien
sûr les emprises et en plus le roi a pas
le choix parce qu'il ya aucune case
n'est jouable donc il faut prendre
on n'a pas d'autres coûts et au regard
des échecs et
j'empêche le roi de venir en dix-sept
puisque et le cavaly contrôle donc où va
le roi par exemple on va dire en fuite
et en plus on attaque la tour donc le
cavalier même pas et même pas en prise
donc on ne peut pas revenir à 8 à cause
de cette variante tout reprend donc ont
peu joué par contre le coup droit j'ai
vite fait de sel alors le problème de
roger 8 évidemment c'est que cette tour
c'est la tour qui a fait l'europe sert
leroy protège la tour mais c'est tour ne
joue pas donc ça veut dire que les noirs
jouent virtuellement avec une pièce de
moins qui est carrément sept tours s'est
jamais bien cette position là c'est tour
ne joue pas du tout le roi est toujours
sous pression
mais bon en contrepartie on voit bien qu
a toujours cette attaque mais regardez
le problème du roi ici c'est qu'il est
toujours sous l'emprise d'un échec est
en réalité la dame a été protégé par le
coucou 17 mais ça ne la protège que que
virtuellement puisque en fait le pion
aux six est prenable
voilà le pion aussi exactement on peut
prendre pour reprendre le système est
alors l'intérêt de tout prendre 6 et 12
c'est un jean lève toute attaque
maintenant sur le cavalier la de
cavaillé protégé par dame et tournait
pas prenable puisque fou prend un tour
sera punie par même où cavaliers 6 échec
au roi et la dame serait pris puisque le
fouet ce parti donc voyez c'est donc là
les noirs ont perdu leur leur pion
central est un pion de côté en plus ici
qui n'est plus là donc les noirs déjà
deux pions - une énorme attaque contre
eux on peut presque dire ici que les
noirs sont sont quasi foutu earth au
juste arrivé à répondre à la menace
suivante touré fuite
touré fuite est une vraie menace parce
que où va la dame si la dame va
n'importe où mais là tout peut être en
prise parce que là ici la tour ne
tiennent que par la menace de découverte
donc ici sur touré fuite on doit réagir
et je les retrouve sans doute la façon
la plus simple de réagir dans cette
position regardez c'est ce qui rend la
partie
c'est ce qui fait basculer la partie
vers une finale gagnante il c'est très
important de savoir faire ce type de
transfert regard des cavaliers cet échec
il a en plus eu et n'auront pas le choix
parce que là il faut prendre l'eau ne
peut pas nier même set puisqu'il ya la
dame donc avec cet échec oblige le coup
suivant faut prendre cette faut prendre
un set et là regardez simplement on fait
d'un prendra maintenant qu'il nommait
change des dames faut prendre le 6 et on
va pas prendre le fou ces six en fait un
gerland est plus malin il prend le fou
et c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi parce qu'il
garde si les prix le fou ces six ans les
noirs auraient sans doute eu simplement
il aurait pris feu les singles chez beta
en fait il est simplement une prime et
je pensais aussi à food & cie ce qui est
moins fort alors l'intérêt aussi c'est
qu'on a une tour une fameuse tour sur la
septième rangée et avec donc toujours
cette tour qui ne joue pas voilà alors
là la finale est quand même on est avec
deux pions plus plus une forte
initiatives sur la 7e c'est facile à
gagner pour ne remettre mais non
petrosur encore chaud quelques coups
après tour et vii unis big août est ce
que tu es là quoi pour échanger les
tours libéré mon roi libéré retour voilà
évidemment sur tours principe ce serait
une mauvaise opération pour les blancs
puisque le roi prend la tour sort il
faut faire attention parce qu'ici on a
quand même des fous de couleurs opposées
opposés et on sait que souvent même
d'options de plus ne suffisent pas pour
ça que petrossian joue encore parce que
parfois il ya des possibilités mais
quand tu es encore des tours c'est
quasiment c'est quasiment futur cd tour
empêche cette mécanique défaut opposé de
jouer surtout s'il est blanc refuse cet
échange
et puis veulent mais maintiennent la
pression en doublant les tours comme
c'est le cas ici voilà alors ça c'est
courant en cas des changes va se
retrouver à nouveau avec une fois
recette exacte donc sur cette lettre il
faut savoir le faire [ __ ] en a quatre
il a laissé le pion à noter qu'il a
laissée le pion mais c'est pas le sujet
et ce qui compte c'est de garder là
toute la pression sur la septième rangée
où vous allez voir parce qu'après b3 qui
consolide les autres pions
on revient en c6 à noter que évidemment
la tour eiffel sete par transparence
contrôler ces sept on ne peut pas faire
tout reprend mais la suite est clair
tourin e6 est ovale fou parce que ce fou
doit rester au contact de la case 8
ça c'est un vrai souci parce que cette
case de 8 empêche d échec mortels voyez
bien que ici est presque mat
la tour qui peut descendre c'est un
thème de couloir qui n'est pas qu'il
n'est pas bon du tout alors ici
petrossian pourrez échanger les tours on
peut voir cette variante
c'est ce qui c'est parce qu'il a choisi
mais après tout reprendre 7
lien le g7 est indéfendable et puis si
c'est est indéfendable donc on va se
retrouver de nouveau avec deux pions de
plus plus ceux qui ont passé plus une
menace sur après tour c'est cette c'est
qu'on attaque le fou en attaque et on
venait ce tour c'est 8 qui aiment les
tours voilà on a ce tour c'est huit
échecs et le roi est obligé d'aller
lever leur arrive ça a été la tour est
perdu donc voyons ceci ouais c'est pas
forcément idéal il joue food et 5 mais
surtout des scènes qui pariaient l'autre
possibilité on peut maintenant devenir
1,8 d'un double idée tout russie s'était
aucune case pour le font donc échec roi
en fin de tour pardon recettes et là
regardez simplement tour on vient ici
donc ici la menace elle et elle est
claire c'est simplement de venir prendre
le pion c'est cette ya pas de problème
avec ça et les noirs ne peuvent pas
prendre la tour puisque tout reprend 3,7
fait et on prend la torah suit donc
simplement on augmente la pression
menace tout reprend et trans est tout
simplement donc ici des abscisses alors
ça c'est un bon coup c'est un des rares
coups on attaque le fou et on se libère
une petite porte pour loin pour enfin
essayer de faire activer cette tour qui
ne joue pas c'est un peu lent mais
est-ce qu'ils avaient le choix donc à
chis regardez maintenant tout reprend on
va prendre le relais c'est magnifique on
ne bouge pas le fou mais on joue quand
même tout repenser cette voie là pas
pourquoi parce qu'en cas de prise bien
sûr et bien
il ya tour échec et on va les bouffer la
torah fuite donc ça permet de gagner un
pion de gagner en temps il faut répondre
à cette menace donc roi g8 avec l'idée
de venir en recettes mais simplement fou
au f4 tranquillement alors à noter que
maintenant bien sûr on peut jouer trois
sets mais sans doute sur 27
on peut regarder d'ailleurs ce qui se
passe sur mon âge c'est sur wells est
simplement jouer d'abord foods g5 et sa
menace
pourtant les 7,6 même matin tout de
suite ça obligerait les noirs a joué
tour g8 donc la tour mais le gris
qu'elle soit sortie serait extrêmement
passive on continuerait la partie
simplement par ces quatre nouvelles fou
et ensuite des singes est simple les
gens mus 17 et dames impossible à
arrêter
donc j'ai cinq parlant
il faut être quatre g5 donc pour ces
raisons peut être qu'un jour je sais
pourquoi j'ai 5 parce que l'idée depuis
trop science et de jouer tout rachète
pour libérer sa cour et non pas de la
sortir autrement donc faut c'est quand
même un tap la tour prend les 15 mois
tour h7 et on prend pas on joue
tours s'est vite pour qu'on ne prend pas
toujours pareil parce que les fouilles
de couleur reposer encore une fois c'est
pas totalement gagné c'est pas du 100 %
c'est pas du sang pour sa 11ème avec ici
trois pions de plus nombre d'options de
plus par dont l'un d'eux sur le plus
mais c'est pas assez production pour son
effectif un an il faut des positions où
c'est gagner mais d'autres où c'est pas
clair et il vaut mieux augmenter son
avantage dans wife set et l'a simplement
ça y est on y va c'est 4 on commence à
avancer les pions donc foulé cette
montre est bien simplement tourné huit
ils se pressent pas quelle heure ne se
pressent pas ton d'élite il aurait pu
jouer autour des 8 pourquoi pas mais est
tombé huit en fait les noirs rejouer des
coups comme 3e 6 et latour protège je me
demande ce que fait la tournée 8 ici on
est plus actif en plus on protège
l'avancée du pion on réussisse quand
même et maintenant voilà l'idée de look
et donc simplement rces c'est qu'ici
échec est encore un pion qui va aller à
la casserole
donc ici attention alors là ça c'est
intéressant parce que quand on commence
à courir après le roi souvent chez amath
horn à la tentation de chercher des
échecs des échecs où il à l air qu
est-ce qui fait et fait ce qu'on appelle
tisser un réseau de maths c'est à dire
qu'il joue un petit coup de pied oui
alors en fait exactement on va le voir
mais pourquoi il joue alors il jouait
froid pourquoi il joue avec trois parce
qu'il veut empêcher
les noirs d'activer leurs droits par là
parce que si on viens par ici ont créé
plus de menaces contre le mois c'est au
roi qu'il devient actif il peut être
pénible soins parce qu'il peut aller
chercher le pion ici peut être qu'ils sa
base
oui ici le pion gouverneur montée on
risque de grappiller tous les pions donc
il faut empêcher quand même cette
manoeuvre est produit accessoirement ex
trois menaces j'ai quatre matches et
voilà et puis même touré fils aussi tour
avec 6 slots est vrai mais aussi g4 se
voit il ya deux menaces de maths en fait
un stoïcisme g4 les deux menaces
matt yamato regarder le roi ne peut plus
du tout bougé cette case est prise par
le pion
cette case est prise ici le fou et bien
sûr protégé par le client des quatre et
sept cases et protégé par le fou donc un
coup comme touriste ou un coup comme g4
fait un échec et mat
mais un matin en plein centre de
l'échiquier donc vous faire attention à
ça donc petrossian joue encore g4 mais
tous réussissent quand même et après 3h
4h des paroles écrites et scène pardon
jour regarder pourquoi on joue j'essaie
un risque à part donc en attaquant g5 en
attaquant le roi et parce qu'on oblige
le seul coup des noirs c'est de jouer
quasiment mais le roi est totalement
déporté il est hors jeu et ne suis rien
ici on fait une menace comme chez les
blancs il est même dans une position et
il y presque matt s'est jamais agréable
et ça laisse et au blanc le temps de
prendre le conditions nécessaires alors
là on peut dire c'est foutu parce que
même en foot que leur poser là on est ce
qu'on appelle deux pions passé qui se
soutiennent donc si on joue appris peu
sur cases blanches conjointe des cinq
puis après on joue c5 c6 il faut
protéger le pion mais on oblige le faut
bouger puis après on jouera des 6-17 et
c'est fini
vous ne tient plus les cases même là là
on pourrait commencer à envisager
d'échanger des tours on a quand même une
position gagnante donc fou et 4 celle ci
a noté la facilité de geller dans la
finale toutes les pièces sont à leur
maximum la tour le fou ne se pressent
pas les prendre de points 6 il sait que
les deux pions passé suffisent il leur
faut quoi pour continuer à avancer un
soutien supplémentaire mais c'est leur
droit
là où le roi noir regarder totalement
hors du jeu le bras blancs s'activent il
va venir ici chercher le fouet puis il
va on va pousser des cinq combats à
mener le roi à la protection et on va
pousser les pions c'est inarrêtable et
puis prendra six avec la tour permettre
au noir d'activer leur propre tour
puisque tours b 7 sera un petit peu
ennuyeux voilà on joue et on
effectivement mais ça a été comme en
protège les trois hommes devraient jouer
la tour en a trois pour protéger la
tour-blanche deviendrait passive et sa
galère ne veut pas la raison d'activer
son roi qui va pouvoir se diriger
tranquillement vers le centre au soutien
de ses pions exactement donc tour
bessette maintenant pour les noirs
l'idée c'est quand même de trouver leur
sur leur salut dans la finale fou de
couleurs opposées mais c'est ce que je
disais maintenant on n'a plus peur de ça
puisque après tout reprendre 17 fou
prend 17 et des 5 c'est fini quel est le
plan des blancs c'est très simple on va
venir en ces trois des quatre protéger
les cinq puis après on joue c4 c5 pardon
c'est 6 on laisse toujours les pions sur
blanc et après pour avancer l'autre on
mettra le roi sur ces cinq et on
avancera regarder on va regarder un peu
la fin en plus trop si rare est ici nous
montre le peu le plan pour ceux qui
veulent comprendre un peu mieux que
mangane ce genre de finale donc après
des cinq si on en veut jouer il vaut
mieux essayer d'activer le roi qui pour
l'instant hors jeu le fou essayant ici
de contrer autant que possible avancé
des pions mois jour roger 6 simplement 3
3 on peut tenter au f5
pourquoi pas mais trois des quatre c'est
le roi ne peut pas passer de toute façon
il a aucune possibilité ici de faire
quoi que ce soit de tout
c'est donc là faut jouer des coudes
attentes ces problèmes d'ailleurs
peut-être on peut c'est pour les noirs
de jouer peut-être un peu plus actifs
plutôt de jouer sans jouer ça peut-être
après 3,3 on va jouer
roy ips qu on va essayer de perdre
wiseid parce que comme ça on va essayer
au moins de me leroy
de ce côté là pour essayer de bloquer et
on va rien bloquer du tout ça et
maintenant on peut pousser
regardez comme le fou qui contrôle les
cases noires et les pions qui menace
d'un an 6 au casque blanc qui se
complètent
que peuvent faire les noirs rien si on
jouera 17 cc6 échec et le fou est perdu
vous possédez pas un problème
on a encore un peu passé en plus
fermement qu'un souci donc une
possibilité c'est d'essayer de venir
peut-être un des mythes et les saluons
tout simplement on pousse alors si les
noirs garde le contact ici pour empêcher
des six
on peut pas jouer des six à cause de la
perte du pion mais simplement voyez que
le comment le roy soutient la lancée de
ses pions et là c'est fini
qu'est ce qu'on fait up née 6 et si par
exemple on journée 8 et dont on peut
faire maintenant fou échec et ensuite
ses échecs puis d'un voile assez facile
donc la partie s'arrête sur après il
faut quatre dans le train de tomber
cette tour prend vous prend et des cinq
ici petrossian abandonnent la partie une
belle partie de galère oui qui a réussi
d'abord dans l'ouverture prendre un peu
davantage de développement il l'a mis à
profit pour nous belle séquence tactique
et ensuite il a réussi à bien convertir
dans une finale qui était relativement
facile à gagner
donc il a fait preuve de tout de toute
sa technique elle va aussi bien dans le
dans le début que dans le milieu de
partie que dans la finale et petrossian
qui malgré qu'ils sont au top de sa
forme en ce moment
en 63 mais a choisi une ouverture et un
peu un peu discutable
oui c'est assez rare que les noirs ne
joue pas ces cinq très rapidement dans
la française se couper six étaient avec
cavalli c6 après il semble quand même un
petit peu suspect il faut ensuite fois
fuite
est ce que je sais que c'était bizarre
c'était bizarre qu'est ce que c'est que
vous et puis voilà belle partie de
galère qui punit petrossian pour un
début un peu mou et qu'il ne fait aucune
erreur dans l'attaqué une très belle
attaque bien menée à à connaître pour
tous ceux qui veulent les prendre
avantage des erreurs parce que si on
prend pas d'avantagé or on ne peut pas
gagner aux échecs ça marche pas merci
jérôme merci stéphane pour ce retour
historique sur et film
guilers et puis moi je vous donne rendez
vous pour une autre émission canal tv au
revoir voir